are you feeding for more of that
punishing at oh so rewarding Dark Souls
goodness ready to slay dragons and die
again and again I've got good news for
you Dark Souls 3 will launch
simultaneously in north america south
america and europe on April twelfth if
that's not good enough for you you can
also save her the brand new gameplay
trailer featuring gruesome enemies
brutal traps and one very angry looking
tree monster it's typical Dark Souls
fair but it looks like a brutal blast
nonetheless from software fans looking
to pre-order the game have a few options
the day one edition collector's edition
apocalypse edition and prestige edition
each include various special packaging
soundtracks and swanky figurines if you
want the lord of cinder on your work
desk now's your chance I know it's hard
but the weight isn't much longer until
then you can visit gamespot for all your
Dark Souls 3 updates and check out our
two-minute break down of Dark Souls lore
I'm Tony Wilson you can follow me on
twitter at chain-gun pope and i'll see
you at the bonfire